[음악]
제가 오늘은 또 신축 현장에 나와
있는데
성수동에 또 최근에 신축이 된게
있어요
엄청 보여요 오늘
볼 빌딩은
8층짜리 빌딩입니다 건물 자체는 지하
2층에 지상 8층짜리 건물 그리고
주차대수가 8대가 필요한데 사실
주차대수 1층에 다 자주식으로 설치를
해버리면
인생 공간이 너무 안 나오기 때문에
두 개씩 주차를 적용을 했고
특이하게도 기획실 주차를 지하에다
설치하지 않고
지상에다가
소음 같은 것도 발생할
인접해 있지만
분리를 시켜놨고 최대한 소음이나 진동
같은 것들이 느껴지지 않도록
흡음재 같은 재료들을
적용을 했습니다 돼지가 몇 평이죠
돼지가 65평 정도
진짜 엄청 커 보여요 지금
옥상에 올라왔는데
뷰가 장난 아니네
진짜 여기에서 어떻게 보면 제일 높은
건물이잖아요
물론 성수동에 이제 큰 건물들 많이
있긴 하지만 우리 페이지 인접해서는
이제 옆에 있는 지식산업센터 외에는
큰 건물들이 없기 때문에 조망이 잘
확보가 돼 있죠
약간 서울숲까지도 보이네요 살짝
저기 응봉산인가요네 남산타워도
보이시죠 남산타워도 보이고 지금 옥상
바닥은 타일 마감으로
적용해서
시공하고 계시고요 저희가 이제
대지면적에
따라서 법적으로 설치해야 되는 조명
면적들이
필요해요
근데 1층에 다 확보하지 못해서 지금
옥상에도 설치를 해서
법정 적용으로 인정을 받으려고 계획을
했습니다 그 법규 관련된 얘기가
나와서 또 말씀을 드리는데 지금
난간이 좀 높기는 해요
근데 사실 난간 높이가 법적
기준으로는 1m 20cm인데 그거를
어느 지점을 기준으로 보느냐에 따라
또 달라져요 저희 같은 경우에는
바닥을 기준으로 보느냐 아
그렇구나 그래서 나중에 사용 검사
받을 때
파라펫이라고 하거든요이 파라펫 끝선을
기준으로 1m 20을 확보하라는
의견이 나오기도 해요 아 그렇구나
그래서 이렇게 하셨구나네 그리고
여기가 이제 8층인데
확실히
이 창이
이렇게 많이 나 있어 가지고 엄청 커
보이네요 여기 약간 테라스 공간도
있네
8층에만
외부 공간이 있습니다
야 이건
중공업직역이
진짜
짱이네요
400%니까
이것도 거의 400% 다
채웠고요 대신에 중공업지역이
가로구역별 최고 높이 제한이
있어요 그게 몇 미터 그게 이제
필지마다 다른데
지정이 돼 있는
필지가 있고
계산을 하게끔 되어 있어요 그래서
토지에 대한 깊이
하고 전면 도로에 대한 이런 것들로
높이를 계산해서
여기 저도
성수동 건물 보면은
400% 다 못 받고 막 300%대
다 그런 것들이 아마 높이 제한
때문에
용적률 확보를 못한 케이스가 있다고
보시면 돼요 그리고 저는 이런 아치형
창문이 되게
약간 뭔가 있는 거 같아요이 느낌이
되게 좀
확 들어오는 거예요
그래서 이은우 이사님께서 디자인 잘
보실 때 그런 아치형태를 좀 포인트로
그래서 건물 전체에서 포인트가 될 수
있게
그렇게 좀 디자인을 해 주셨어요
그래서 전면부에는 큰 가치들이
세계층을 연결하게끔 구성이 되어
있고이 측면에는 이렇게 각 층별로
작은 알찬 창문들이 있어요 그래서이
패턴을 연속적으로 이어가기 위해서
우리 아까 외부 나갔었는데 거기도
아치형으로
약간 그 유럽의
항상 말씀하시는 것처럼
계단실이랑
엘리베이터 홀에는
이게 있고 없고 차이가 큽니다 만약에
이게 없었으면
물론 이제 조명이 있지만 좀 되게
어두웠을 것 같아요
무조건 설치해야 되는 거 같아요
약간 그 있잖아요
약간 빛 들어왔을 때 그 느낌
더 이제 해가 질 때 보면은
창을 통해서 이제
빛들이 떨어지는 그림자가 더
확연하게
져서
깨끗하게 볼 수 있죠 그리고 저희
건물 규모가 있기 때문에 전층 다
지금 스프링쿨러 설치되어 있어요 여기
다 있네요
그리고 전열 교환기라 그래서 내부
1개 해주는 그런 시스템
적용되어 있고요
급백이고를 통해서 공기를
순환시켜줍니다
화장실은 복도를 통해서
상구척하고 좀 다른 점이 이제 창에
위치들이 크기들이
작아졌네요 위층에는 창들은 이제
바닥까지 내려오는 큰 타입의
창이었다면 여기는 이제 하부에 이제
턱이 있는 타입이고
이쪽 화장실에 있는 구간인데 여기가
지상기계식 주차 상부
지분이에요 아 그렇구나 그래서 이제
높이가 좀 필요하기 때문에 한 단이
생겼어요 그런 부분이 조금 다르고
3층 가시면 또 내부 공간 창의
위치들이 또 다
달라집니다
여기는 좀 뭐라 해야 되지 아까는 좀
환한 느낌이었다면 여기는 뭔가 좀
뭔가 좀 집중되는 느낌
약간 그런 느낌이 드는 거 같아 또
탕에 위치나 아
여긴 또 이제 이렇게 아치형으로
1층부터 3층까지 연결되는 큰 아치
창이 3층에서는 이제 보여지는 거죠
여기는 오피스도 있지만 이제 약간
근생으로도 줘도 될 거 같아요
저층분을 좀 근생 용도로 고려를 하고
있는데
식당이나 뭐 이런 것도 괜찮고
여기가 이제 그래서
4층까지는 큰 면적을 좀 쓸 수
있었으면 1 2 3층은 면적이 좀 더
협소해져요
이게 층마다 좀 공간이 재밌는 거
같아요
진짜이 건물에는 다 있는 거 같아요
아예 열려 있는 거
조금 닫혀 있는 거 그 다음에 좀
다른 형태로 열려 있는 거
이렇게
우리가 많이 봐왔던 일반적인
지하 1층에 내려와 있습니다
사실 지하층 공간을 더 크게 써야
되는데이 기계식
주차하고요 저희
지하 같은 경우에는 비상탈출구나
흔한 계단이 있어야 되잖아요
여기 이제 사다리가 설치되게
지하 같은 경우에는 이제
습기
차원에서 보호해주기 위해서 강습법이
있어요 안쪽으로 혹시 누수가 됐을 때
물을
아무래도 신축 건물이다 보니까
지하층까지도 엘리베이터 다 연결이
되고요
저희 기계식 주차장은 총 8대가
돌아가는 수직
순환식이고요 일식 주차는 이제 중국
검사를 다 받았어요
앞쪽에 이제
포장이랑 이런 마감들이 좀 남아가지고
내부에도
텅 테이블이 있고
외부에도 선 테이블이 있어요
외부에서도 이용하실 수 있게 선택을
설치했고
그러니까 그 차라리 그냥 기계식으로
설치한게 나은 거 같아요
1층을 살려 놓은게 되게 좀 잘한 거
같아요 1층 임대 무늬가 굉장히 많이
고쳤어요 만약에 중공업 지역에
여러분들도 땅이 좀 크지 않은데
이렇게 좀 높게 신축을 계획한다고
하면은 그 기계식 주차를 설치하는
것도 한번 생각해 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다 그리고이 주차장 뒤쪽으로
이제 조경
먼저 파포 아 이쪽이에요 사실
큰 식재들은 조금 다 옥상에다가
배치를 했어요 아무래도 이제 건물
사이에 있는 공간이다 보니까
식재가 좀 자라게 좋은 환경은
성수동 중고
지역의 신축된 사례를 좀 왔는데
저희가 기존에 4호층짜리 건물 봤던
거랑은
완전 좀 스케일이 좀 다른 거 같아요
건물도
훨씬 더 커 보이고 대지 65평으로도
진짜 용도지역이 높아서 이렇게 건물이
또 크게 보일 수 있는 그런 효과가
있는 거 같아요 그래서
삼점 같은 경우에는 용적률
250%잖아요 근데 이제 중공업지는
거의 400%니까 그 땅에 활용도가
되게 높거든요 그래서
요것처럼
준공업 지역에 이렇게 좀 되게 멋지게
지은 사례가 있으니까 여러분들도
참고하셔서 이렇게 준공업 지역에
투자하신다고 했을 때 좀 도움이
되셨으면 좋겠습니다 그래서 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다